welcome to 3abn today Bible Q&A my name
is JD Quinn I'm going to be your host
it's my privilege to introduce to you
our three panel persons are our guest
our three ABN brothers and sisters
that's the bottom line and it's Daniel
pin at the end Daniel welcome thank you
it's good to be here I love the Bible
Q&A program because we get to hear God's
word and study amen amen and hopefully
we're Guided by the our Answers by the
Holy Spirit know that you've mentioned
that before and it's so important and
Ivonne Ivon Shelton welcome thank you so
much it's great to be here I'm looking
forward to unpacking the word of God
Amen and Shelley Quinn hello Shelley
Quinn hello there
stranger I am so pleased to get to
participate in this we want to thank you
so much for submitting your questions
because you give us the opportunity to
research the scripture and give you a
good answer in a short time in a short
time that's exactly right how do we get
these questions they come from you we're
blessed and I know that many times
there's a lot of study that goes in
exactly how should I word that so if you
want to send your questions in to us
let's talk about text first and that's
618 228
3975 one more time 618 228 397 5 perhaps
you would like to email it if that's the
if that's so then that's Bible QA at
3abn.org
by in a hurry 5 minutes goes by in a
hurry so number one to Daniel before we
start let's have prayer thank you Jesus
father as we come before you today in
the name of Jesus I Want to Thank You
Lord that we can bring all things to you
sometimes Lord it just get so busy that
sometimes we may forget that's not who
we choose to be father this is about you
this is your this is your time Lord this
is your word and father I just thank you
for the inspiration for each person here
and father we just ask Lord as we just
have these questions Lord that'll touch
people's hearts their answers will be
answered we give you all praise all
glory in the name of Jesus amen amen
thank you Jesus
amen Daniel I understand why Abel isn't
in Adam's genealogy but why isn't Cain
listed in Genesis 5 this is coming from
Pennsylvania all right thank you for
this question and as you noted Abel's
genealogy isn't there because he was
killed by his brother Cain and Seth's
genealogy this would be the third child
of Adam and Eve uh is in chapter 5 and
it describes nine righteous Generations
ending with Noah uh in Genesis 5 and
then the story of Noah leads us into the
flood chapter 6 7 8 and N of of Genesis
and then that leads us to the Tower of
Babel and then to continuing Noah's uh
genealogy up to Abraham and what Abraham
and what comes uh through Abraham so the
gene ology of Genesis 5 is the second
part of a contrast between two families
that represent two attitudes toward God
Cain's genealogy is actually reported in
the Bible uh at least part of it and
that's in Genesis 4: 16- 24 these verses
uh present six Generations that came
following Cain and it makes it clear
that Cain's family continued and began
to spread out upon the earth now the
Bible doesn't follow his family in
detail as it does with cth genealogy but
we see some principles Illustrated
through the names that follow in Cain's
family tree we see city building and
then we see exalting the human over the
Divine especially by naming the city
after PE members of the family we see
polygamy and murder and pride and
Defiance against God there's no
indication that there is a character of
righteousness that is pursued or were
nourished by this family and and nothing
that is passed down as we see in the
family line of Seth now what happened to
Cain's family line well it came to an
end completely at the flood and it does
not continue after that point see Noah
and his sons were in Seth's family line
and there's no indication that they
married outside they didn't intermarry
uh Noah's children with those from the
family of Cain and so Cain's genealogy
then comes to an end there at the flood
now these two families illustrate for us
that there are two families in the world
even today and we see this actually in
the Book of Romans 5: 12 to 21 which
Compares two families from which we have
an have inherited traits there's the
family of Adam from which we receive sin
and condemnation and death or by
contrast there's the family of Christ
from which we receive the free gift of
righteousness and eternal life now you
were born into the family of Adam but
the good news is you don't have to stay
there you have a choice of families and
that was true from every for everybody
of all time all the way back to Adam and
Eve they had a choice about which family
they wanted to belong to and we do too
amen great
answer ion great question how can I
become closer to Jesus if I'm always
busy
M this really is a good question and I
think most of us are so caught up in our
day-to-day activities that we can often
lose sight of what's really important we
often find ourselves too busy to connect
with God and so there's some concrete
steps that we can take in order to
address this whole issue of making time
for the Savior the first thing is that
we should look at Jesus's pattern he
always made time to pray in Matthew
14:23 it says and I quote and when he
had sent the multitudes away he went up
to the mountain by himself to pray now
when the evening came he was alone there
end quote from this we can see that even
after a long day in Ministry Jesus took
the time to connect with his
father how many times do we say that
we're too tired or too busy probably
more times than we really careed to
remember and then we should follow
Christ's pattern of starting the day
with the father he often prayed early in
the morning Mark 1 uh: 35 says now in
the morning having risen a long while
before daylight he went out and departed
to a solitary place and there he prayed
end quote Jesus enjoyed that quiet time
with the father and that was how he
began his day and that's how we should
begin our days by plugging in to the
power source of the
father don't make Jesus an
afterthought seek Him First Matthew 6:33
says but seek first the kingdom of God
and his righteousness and all these
things will be added to you and then we
need to be intentional about our
priorities Colossians 3: 1 and 2 says if
then you've been raised with Christ seek
the things that are above where Christ
is seated at the right hand of God God
set your minds on things that are above
not on things that are on the earth and
then we should be diligent in making our
plans Proverbs 215 says the plans of the
diligent lead surely to abundance but
everyone who is Hasty comes only to
Poverty so when we are going about our
daily routine we should remember to
practice the presence I know my sister
Shel has talked about practicing the
presence of God practice feeling him
sensing him with you talk to him don't
leave him out of your day the devil
wants to distract us he wants to take us
somewhere else have us so busy that we
don't think about the Lord but follow
the Lord's pattern make time for the
father every single day make time make
it a priority and when you do this you
will experience an abundance of peace
and joy and love in your life amen good
answer good answer Shelly your first
question I have heard several different
understandings about Genesis 4 veres 4
and 5 regarding Cain and Abel's
offerings why was Cain's offering
rejected and Abel's accepted the
scripture does not go into why but I've
heard that Cain did not offer an animal
because of the blood I've also heard it
said that because of Cain's firstling
meaning first born and the term first
fruits and this is from Charlotte
Charlotte this is an excellent question
and let me just give you a clue about
something when you are looking for the
answer to anything we always say context
but we have to look not just in the
context of the chapter but actually the
whole Bible when Adam and Eve sinned in
Genesis 3 we see they recognize they
were nied they lost their covering of
light they lost the righteousness of God
so what they do they made fig aprons and
then they hid from God but Genesis 3:21
tells us after God came down and sought
them out that he made tunics of skin for
them to do so he had to have killed an
animal and most likely a lamb and he
introduced the
substitutionary sacrificial system that
pointed to the Messiah Christ
now he taught Adam and Eve this and they
were very blessed by it obviously they
taught their
sons here's something you have to
remember Genesis chapters 1 through1
covers 2,000 years of Earth's history in
11 chap chapters and then there's
another 300 so
2300 years in Genesis but even though
the abbreviated account doesn't tell us
that they explained it to a uh Abel and
Cain they obviously did here's what the
Bible says Genesis 4:4 God respected
Abel in his offering and the New
Testament affirms here's where we're
seeing it throughout the Bible in
Hebrews
11:4 by faith Abel offered to God a more
excellent sacrifice than Cain through
which he obtained witness that he was
righteous so Abel had faith in God's
substitutionary sacrificial plan he knew
the coming Messiah was the only way
believing and trusting in Him that he
could be restored to righteousness and
he brought this this little lamb
according to God's plan to sacrifice as
his
substitute Jesus affirmed that Abel was
righteous in Matthew
23:35 he says he spoke of the righteous
blood of Abel or the blood of righteous
Abel now going back in Genesis 4:5 Cain
disregarded the Divine instruction and
he was a farmer and what did he do he
said I'll bring of my own works so he
brought some of his fruit from the
ground God rejected it and Romans 2:11
tells us there's no partiality with God
so God's rejection was not arbitrary he
was simply affirming the Divine truth
that he no one could be made righteous
by self effort and God comes trying to
to correct Cain he says in Genesis 4 ver
7 if you do well will you not be
accepted in other words why aren't you
listening to me if you do not do well
sin lies at the door and its desire is
for you but you should rule over it amen
good good Daniel your second question
can you please tell me why there was a
fight over Moses's body and this is from
Andy in Texas thank you Andy for your
question and your ask asking about Jude
1 the only chapter in Jude verse 9 that
says Yet Michael the Archangel in
contending with the devil that's Satan
when he disputed about the body of Moses
and there's the line you're referring to
dared not bring against him a reviling
accusation but said the Lord rebuke you
now we know that Moses was raised to
life he visits with Jesus at the
Transfiguration and so this conflict
arises over whether or not Moses could
be raised from the dead and here's the
thing two supernatural beings claimed
the right to Moses the first was Michael
the Archangel who has the power to
resurrect this is Jesus and we know this
when we look at you can look at First
Corinth 1 Thessalonians 4:16 that says
it is the voice of the Archangel that
raises the dead when Jesus comes John
5:25 says it's the voice of the Son of
God and so this is the Son of God this
is Jesus who is coming to claim Moses
and there's another angel rebellious
Angel the devil formerly called Lucifer
and he is surprised because Moses had
died a sinner and he was not like Enoch
who had been taken to heaven in his
lifetime in fact God himself had buried
him we find that in Deuteronomy 34:6 and
so Satan thought to himself I've been
Victorious I claim this person as my own
I have rightful possession over him and
one by one he was winning all of
humanity or so he thought dying and
being buried in the grave and Moses was
a real prize because he was the meekest
man on Earth and he's the one who spoke
with God and saw him face to face but
even he had stumbled and failed at a
crucial point where he was supposed to
illustrate the intercession with God of
God for us and so now all of a sudden he
realizes I'm not Victorious I have not
been Victorious and he said you don't
have the right to raise him he's a
sinner he doesn't deserve it and Jesus
says Sinners well Jesus shows he
illustrates Sinners can be saved how
it's not through their good works it is
through the righteousness of Christ when
they put their faith in that how could
he do this when Jesus had not yet died
for our sins and a brief reference of
four texts here Revelation 138 that he
is the lamb slain from the foundation of
the world Titus 1:2 eternal life which
God who cannot lie promised Before Time
began Ephesians 1:4 he chose us in him
that's in Christ before the foundation
of the world in 1 Peter 1:20 he indeed
was foreordained before the foundation
of the world Satan cannot stop what God
assures through Jesus Christ Satan knew
that his defeat was being announced and
demonstrated and assured in advance
Sinners can be saved and he cannot not
hold anyone in the grave who's put their
faith in Jesus that's what the fight is
all about amen great answer Evon your
second question can you please explain
Leviticus
21:5 do these laws apply to us
today that's a great question when we
are looking to understand a passage or
verse we have to always ask ourselves to
whom was this written who was being
addressed
in this verse in Leviticus 21:1 it says
and the Lord said to Moses speak to the
priests the son of Aaron and say to them
None Shall defile himself for the dead
among his people so this chapter in
Leviticus is clearly addressing the
priests of Israel and actually the whole
chapter could borrow its title from
Malachi 2 verse one that says and now oh
you priest this is this commandment is
for you so Leviticus 21 is a chapter
admonishing the priest to preserve the
Dignity of the priesthood so now let's
look at verse five quote they shall not
make any bald place on their heads nor
shall they shave the edges of their
beards nor make any cuting in their
flesh end quote these were superstitious
practices of the Heathen they would cut
off their hair they would cut themselves
and blood let you we saw that with
Elijah and the and the prophets of ba on
Mount Carmel so the the Heathen priests
would do all of these different things
trying to invoke these
deities that um were in um that were
actually imaginary and the people
thought that these deities presided over
the dead so they were mourning for their
Dead trying to get favor with these
deities and they would cut thems eles
they would shave their heads and it was
just all these different Heathen
practices and the devil was all involved
in that and God was letting the priest
know you are not to do that you are not
to mourn for your dead as the Heathen
do the priests were to teach the people
the statutes of God and the difference
between clean and unclean as we see in
Leviticus 10: 10 and 11 they were not to
be extravagant in the expression of
their mourning nor Superstitious by
cutting themselves and shaving their
heads and so Leviticus 215 addresses the
practices of the Heathen in defacing
their bodies with signs of mourning for
the dead these practices were forgiven
were forbidden Deuteronomy 189
says when you come into the land the
Lord your God has given you you shall
not learn to follow the
Abominations of these nations so God was
letting the people know you are not to
practice these
Heathen um ways you're not to take on
the Heathen ways you are to maintain the
Dignity of the priesthood and the
priests were to share this with the
people amen thank you thank
you
Shelly this is interesting question who
is Jesus oh I love it I hope you have a
pen and paper I'm going to give you a
number of scriptures very quickly who is
Jesus he is God who came down to earth
to take on human flesh we see that in
Philippians
25-8 I'm getting there I'm ahead of
myself John 1 1-5 says in the beginning
was the word and the Word was with God
the Word was God and nothing was created
that was created except by him so all
things were created through him Isaiah
7:14 Matthew
1:23 says he is
Emmanuel God With Us Colossians 2:9 says
in him dwells in Jesus dwells all the
fullness of the godhead bodily
Philippians 25-8 that I referenced
earlier says he is the Eternal God who
was equ equal to God who humbled himself
to come to Earth the Lord Of Glory
stepped out of heaven and came to Earth
to Humble himself take on human flesh to
become the son of man and the Covenant
Son of God and then what did he do he
continued in his humiliation and he
humbled himself to die on the cross for
our sin Jesus possesses every attribute
of God because he is God he is eternal
and he has his eternal nature of Love
there was never a time that Jesus did
not exist the O the only time that he
was issued forth was when he was birthed
from Mary's womb he was conceived by the
Holy Spirit and what happened when she
conceived she conceived a pre-existing
person that was his God nature but then
it was her seed he's he's the promised
seed of Genesis 3:15 they were knitted
together and he was fully God and fully
man Colossians 1:15 through1 17 says
he's the image of the invisible God the
first born now you've got to understand
firstborn is a covenant title that means
he holds
preeminence he's the firstborn over all
creation for by him all things were
created that's why he's got the
preeminence that are in heaven and on
Earth visible and in invisible he is
before all things and in him all things
consist so Jesus Christ who was the
creator did not was not himself
created who who is Jesus not only is he
the promised seed the deliverer
announced in the garden Genesis 3:15 but
as you've already mentioned in
Revelation 138 in anticipation of the
crucifixion Revelation 138 says he was
the lamb who was slain from the
foundation of the world he came to Earth
this wasn't an afterthought this was
planned among the godhead and one of
them the second person of the godhead
came down to become a man to die for us
and pay our sin penalty and satisfy his
own Justice against sin 2 Corinthians
5:21 he's our Savior and Lord and it
says he made God made him who knew no
sin Jesus Christ to be sin why that we
might become the righteousness of God in
him Jesus is the one who who inaugurated
and ratified the New Covenant by his own
blood that's Hebrews 13:20 the blood of
the Everlasting Covenant in 1
Corinthians
15:45 it says he's the last Adam that
means he's the new representative of
mankind he overcame every Temptation he
is our high priest he finished his work
here on the Earth but Hebrews 7 24- 2781
and2 says now continues his ministry on
our behalf as a high priest and he is a
priest who is sympathetic because he
understands us and he invites us to come
boldly before his throne of grace to
receive help in our time of need there's
only one mediator between God and man
second first Timothy 25 and6 and that
mediator is Jesus
Christ amen amen great great
answer how do you contact us I want to
take a few seconds and uh give you those
numbers again if you're going to text at
618 228
3975 if you choose to email Bible QA
3abn.org
can you please explain Luke
9:27 and this is from Phil in Florida
Phil let's read together Luke 9:27 which
starts like this but I tell you truly
this is Jesus speaking here I tell you
truly there are some standing here who
shall not taste death till they see the
kingdom of God now this story is
actually also in Matthew chapter 16 and
Mark chapter 9 now I believe that what
Jesus said here was perfectly clear to
him he's the word made flesh and this
reminds us that our spiritual eyesight
is very dim because what is clear to God
we struggle to understand so we must go
to him to be enlightened and led by the
holy spirit so let's look at the context
which has already been mentioned before
in Luke the context in Luke is that
Jesus would not let them make him King
no earthly Kingdom then he said that he
was going to be killed no earthly
Kingdom and then he rebuked Peter when
Peter rebuked him for saying that he was
going to be killed and then Jesus
described the second coming the future
where his Heavenly Kingdom would be
would be revealed and experienced so it
may seem now that his second coming is
what he's talking about which is not
really the case it might be partially
true we'll see and so then after that
after Jesus has made clear he's not
setting up an Earthly Kingdom he makes
this statement that some standing here
will not taste death until they see the
kingdom of God and in all three gospels
where Jesus makes this statement it's
followed immediately by the story of the
Transfiguration where Jesus up on the
mountain radiates the glory of God God's
Kingdom Glory that that that shines
forth from his presence the disciples
saw this Glory of God's righteousness
and they also witnessed Moses and Elijah
as examples of the resurrected and
translated Saints who uh go to heaven
without dying
and furthermore each of the gospels who
tells this story right between Jesus
makes that statement and the
Transfiguration they include a Time
statement after six days after six days
or about eight days those are the three
statements they make and each of these
time statements then creates a link
between one story and here's the time
that happened between we get to the next
story which makes it clear that these
stories are linked together and the
gospel writers understood that the
Transfiguration of Jesus on the mount
Mountain where he radiates his his true
divine glory is the Fulfillment of that
promise that Jesus made at least the
initial fulfillment what I mean by that
is that ultimately when we understand
what the Bible teaches about death that
uh you sleep in the grave until Jesus
comes then we know that there were some
standing there who will not taste death
they will taste sleep but they will not
taste death until Jesus does come in his
glory and they will see his kingdom and
Power in the restored uh new Earth which
uh comes a time after Jesus second
coming so the some standing there who
saw the glory of God are the few of
Jesus disciples who saw the
Transfiguration man very
good Ivon this is a long
question is it a sin not to love
yourself or to be constantly lacking of
your own confidence because of how you
look or because of your personality the
Bible tells us to love others as we love
ourselves but if I don't really care
about myself or love
myself but yet I really love others is
that okay is selflove and appreciation
biblically important for a Christian
wow there actually two parts to your
question that I really want to address
first of all it seems as though you have
some personal insecurities about your
looks or your
personality and that's a common
situation because many of us have things
about ourselves that we wish we didn't
have or would like to have differently
but when these things overwhelm if if
you begin to feel overwhelmed about it
then we have to step back and look at
what the word says about who you are
first of all the Bible says in Genesis
1:27 that we were formed in the image of
God and that he has known who you would
become before you were even born
Jeremiah 1:5 says before I formed you in
the womb I knew you before you were born
I Sanctified you I ordained you a
prophet to the Nations and so from these
verses we find that we were created in
God's image and known by him before we
were even born and then think about this
you are unique there's no one exactly
like you Ephesians 2:10 says for we are
his workmanship created in Christ Jesus
for good works which God prepared
beforehand that we should walk in them
so you're special you're unique and most
importantly you're are God's child
you're so valuable that the father sent
his only son to die for you so the Bible
offers us the confidence in our position
in Christ through Jesus we are children
of God and if children then heirs Heirs
of God and fellow heirs with Christ
Christ according to Romans 8: 16 And1 17
so it's important that you recognize who
you are in Christ and don't compare
yourself with others 2 Corinthians 10:12
says not that we dare to classify or
compare ourselves with some of those who
are commending themselves but when they
measure themselves by one another um and
compare themselves with one another they
are without understanding so when the
Devil comes at you and tries to make you
feel like you are not enough remind
yourself to whom you belong and then
secondly as far as biblical self-love is
concerned Jesus statement to love our
neighbor as we do ourselves doesn't
imply Pride or conceit it rather
involves what we do instinctively we
protect ourselves from harm or death or
we eat to supply energy to our bodies so
it's a natural thing for us to take care
of our bodies and this is what
demonstrates self-love it's an intrinsic
characteristic of Being Human we keep
ourselves from dying we try to preserve
our lives and these are the things that
Jesus wants us to notice about others
around us our neighbors do they have
food do they have shelter do they have
clothing do we care about them that is
what we should be looking at in terms
of how to love our neighbors as
ourselves that was beautiful amen great
very good
Shelly another long question did God
show partiality to live because Jacob
was so in love with Rachel it seems like
that's the case because the priesthood
priesthood came through Levi and the
kings came through Judah who were both
sons of Leah and this is from Anne in
Pennsylvania and let me give you four
quick scripture references you know
after uh Peter had the vision of the
sheets God showed him the clean and the
unclean said go eat he said no no I've
never eaten anything unclean acts 10
verses 34 and 35 acts 10:34 and 35 Peter
finally understood and he actually tells
the Jewish Brethren most certainly and
thoroughly I I now perceive and
understand that God shows no part well
he's speaking to Cornelius here that God
shows no partiality he is no respector
of people I believe Paul says that again
in Romans 2:11 somewhere around there in
Matthew
23:12 the Bible says Jesus says whoever
exalts himself will be humbled whoever
humbles himself will be exalted Jacob
loved Rachel but he was tricked into
marrying her older sister Leah and his
preference he ended up if you don't know
this they he married both sisters within
a week at the end the wedding week with
Leah he married Rachel and then had to
work for her another seven years but his
preference for Rachel caused all kinds
of trouble Leah was a Praying Woman she
cried out to God repeatedly and a
woman's social status was very much her
Prestige was measured by how many sons
she gave her husband yes the Bible says
Genesis 29:
31-35 that God takes pity on her it says
when the Lord saw that Leah was unloved
he opened her womb but Rachel was Barren
and then Leah bore Ruben for she said
the Lord has surely seen my Affliction
she bore another son she says oh the
Lord has heard I was unloved she bore a
third son Levi a fourth son but then in
Genesis 30 verse 17 it says God listened
to Leah she was praying all the time and
he she gave a fifth and sixth son and a
daughter to Jacob and then it says in
verse 32 God remembered Rachel and God
listened to her and opened her whoop it
wasn't any preferential treatment but
God took pity and he heard her
cries amen amen good good good good
Daniel your fourth question
I have been hearing that by living a
healthy lifestyle with exercising Godly
principles you can extend your
lifespan but my understanding from
scriptures such as job
145 Matthew
627 Psalms 139 verse 16 is that God has
already determined our Length of days
can you please clarify all right a
healthy lifestyle is a wonderful gift
that God gives us and we get to
participate in it thank you Jesus for
that but can we actually extend our life
lots of people would like to do that I
think let's take a look at those three
texts you mentioned job 14:5 says since
his days are determined the number of
his months is with you you have
appointed his limits so that he cannot
pass all right Matthew 6:27 says which
of You by worrying can add one cubit to
his stature any worriers out there okay
and Psalm 139:16 says your eyes saw my
substance being yet unformed and in your
book they were WR they all were written
the days fashion for me when as yet
there were none of them now here's what
we know from the Bible all life comes
exclusively from God I cannot wrestle
out of God's hand extra life that he
chooses not to give to me just because I
have earned it by my temperate lifestyle
and if he determines that those days
don't belong to me they're not mine and
I cannot snatch them away from him these
texts that you've mentioned don't mean
that God uh arbitrarily predetermines
your lifespan but that God sees the end
from the beginning he knows you start to
finish and the God who sees the end from
the beginning offers you the freedom to
choose and to choose what to do with the
life that he's given you now God offers
you the best options he offers you the
best choices and if we make those
choices we can live life to its fullest
the Abundant Life God determines our
limits but we also play a role our
selfish habits and for most of us
there's quite a few of them our selfish
habits tend to reduce God's plan for our
lives our healthful living doesn't
really extend our life it just helps us
to draw closer to the potential that God
wants for you from the beginning think
of it this way my car has roughly a
300,000 m LIF span so they tell me and I
can treat my car I can drive it in such
a way I can put things into it that will
help that vehicle to reach or or get
close to that ideal now we might call
this extending the life or the engine or
the transmission of my car but really
what I'm doing is just helping it to
realize the potential that was built
into it from the beginning on the other
hand there's a lot of things that I can
do with my driving and what I put in my
vehicle that can certainly shorten the
lifespan of my car right think of this
text in Ecclesiastes 7:17 which is an
interesting text to to go study but it
it it introduces a great applicable
principle sayso not be overly Wicked nor
be foolish why should you die before
your time in other words you can shorten
the years shorten the time that God has
given you let me give you a similar text
here uh to the ones that you mentioned
it's Romans 8:29 and3 which says for
whom he fornew he also predestined to be
conformed to the image of his son that
he might be the firstborn among many
Brethren moreover whom he predestined he
also called whom he called these he also
Justified and whom he justified these he
also glorified this tells us that God
planned in advance for your salvation
but we have a choice of whether or not
to participate with what God planned in
advance and not everybody is going to
accept what God planned in advance and
made possible you see how this relates
here we can shorten what God promised
God raised up Kings but not all those
kings lived up to that potential if they
had followed God they could have what we
might call Extended their reign by
simply realizing what God wanted for
them so why a health message let me give
you six reasons why God gives us a
health message number one the body is
his it belongs to him let's operate it
his way he knows how best to operate it
number two it helps us to live longer so
we can serve him and love him and know
him longer number three it gives us the
privilege and the opportunity to enjoy
the benefits that God has for us number
four Our Lives can be an eye-catching
visual aid of what the kingdom of God is
like that's one of restoration and
strong health and also the body number
five is INS searat connected to the mind
and the mind is where decisions are made
made those decisions that connect us
with God and finally God gives us a
health message so that we can learn
daily habits of obedience self-control
and submission to the will of God rather
than submission to our appetites the sin
degraded appetites that that Satan
inspires and brings in places before us
so like we can't extend our life but we
can certainly live up to the potential
that God has given us amen amen well put
well put Ivon your fourth question
question what does the poor in spirit
mean in Matthew
5:3 well thank you so much for that
question um when we look in Matthew 5
and Luke 6 we find the Beatitudes and
that was a part of Jesus's Sermon on the
Mount and the Beatitudes contain some
really interesting facets about them
that we can examine and then we'll apply
that to your question so first of all
all the Beatitudes start with the word
blessed blessed
but when we think of someone that's
blessed we think of an endowment
probably from the Lord right the Lord
has blessed us but in this case in the
original language it really could be
translated into happy so instead of
being like a feeling instead of it being
an endowment from God it is an attitude
that the person has they are happy so
let's let's kind of substitute the word
happy for blessed because back in those
times back in Bible times the
philosophers thought that happiness was
the end was the the the end of all
things it was the ultimate goal of all
things but uh
Christ focused on making us happy by
making us holy his he connected
happiness and Holiness excuse me Christ
proposed his Doctrine by using
paradoxical dogmas so blessed are the
poor poor in spirit or happy are the
poor in spirit for theirs is the Kingdom
of Heaven happy are those who mourn for
they shall be comforted they're these
two seemingly
disconnected uh factors but yet Christ
connected them because he was showing
that that uh our happiness really comes
through
Holiness according to one commentary the
poor in spirit are the truly humble you
know when we think of poverty we think
of lack we think of what someone is is
missing well those who are poor in
spirit know that that they are wretched
and poor and naked and blind as as in
found in um Revelation where the Bible
talks about the Church of leod deia the
poor in spirit are humble they are truly
humble and they are aware of their great
spiritual poverty ignorance sinfulness
guilt depravity and weakness but this
humility renders them teachable and meek
and submissive and patient and contented
and cheerful to be poor in spirit is to
have a humble opinion of yourself to be
aware that we are all sinners and have
no righteousness of our
own excuse me to be willing to be saved
only by the rich grace and mercy of God
to be willing to be wherever God places
us to Bear what he lays on us to go
wherever he leads us and to do whatever
he tells us this is what it means to be
poor in spirit the poor in spirit feel
within them the opposite of having
enough you know that you just don't have
the internal resources to do what needs
to be done to change ourselves we have
to obtain righteousness by faith in
Christ my sister here with the
righteousness by
faith and so being poor in spirit is
really the opposite of having enough and
of wanting nothing from a moral point of
view and an example of this would be the
tax collector uh in Luke 18:
10-14 so when we're poor in spirit we
are happy because the Kingdom of Heaven
is present within us we are happy
because we have right ousness peace and
joy in the Holy Ghost as found in Romans
14:17 being poor in spirit is a goal
that we should all have to know that our
sufficiency comes from Christ amen
beautiful beautiful praise the Lord
Shelly your fourth question I'm having
problems or am I'm having some trouble
understanding 1 Timothy 43 and 4 okay
can we pray over over our food in other
words they're saying they pork Etc and
make it
okay uh this is a wonderful question
some people are very confused and
misguided about this so let's let's look
at this first of all context Paul is
warning Timothy and he he's talking
about the apostasy that's in the church
he's worried and uh it's caused by the
demonic spirits who are mixing air with
the truth of God's word and he's warning
against the mystical charismatic
concepts of the gnostics who were
introducing in 1 Timothy 4:3 let's look
that forbidding to marry well see the
gnostics believed all matter was evil
and the human body was evil marriage was
sinful so they were forbidding to marry
marriage is Honorable in God's eyes he
is the one who created the institution
of marriage between a male and a female
in the Garden of Eden then look at 1
Timothy
4:3 it says and
commanding to abstain from foods which
God created to Beed with
Thanksgiving okay so God created some
foods to be rece received with
Thanksgiving who believe and know the
truth it says let's read that again it's
confusing commanding to abstain from
foods which God created to be received
with Thanksgiving by those who believe
and know the truth the gnostics were
Aesthetics they believed in fasting and
abstinence they believed that eating
foods that were sacrificed to Demons
meant that those demonic spirits would
forces would enter your body body they
believed that for ritualistic reasons
that there were some foods that they
just flat said don't eat they went
beyond the word of God in limiting what
man can eat but now let's look at First
Timothy
44 every creature of God is good what
did God say at the end of creation ah
it's good I mean he made the pigs he
made the catfish he made he made the
clean and the unclean clean but he
called them all good because they all
had a
purpose and so it says every creature of
God is good nothing is to be refused if
it is received with
Thanksgiving ah now some people are
going aha we don't have to worry about
clean and unclean but look what it says
in verse 5 for it is
Sanctified by the word of God In Prayer
most people make it it's like like it's
Sanctified by prayer if I just pray over
this ham I can eat it and think God is
going to be okay with that but look what
it says everything nothing is to be
refused with Thanksgiving that's been
Sanctified by the word of
God Sanctified
means that it is set apart as holy and
acceptable to God clean means it is set
apart as holy and acceptable to God what
Paul is doing here he limits his
conversation to that which was created
by God as food the first diet for
Humanity was Genesis
1:29 that's the herbs I mean the
vegetarian vegan if you will will but
God by his word Sanctified that and in
the days of Noah
well before the levitical laws of of of
diet in the days of Noah God
distinguished between the clean and the
unclean he called seven pair of clean
animals onto the ark whereas it was only
one pair of unclean why because only
clean could be eaten After the flood and
only clean could be used for sacrifice
so we just know that it has to be
Sanctified by the word of God God has
never there's nothing in the Bible that
has ever banished his
instructions he didn't lift the ban on
unclean Foods anytime in scripture amen
thank you very well put let's take a few
seconds here a few minutes and go to an
address call and we'll come back and
we'll see if we have any additional
thoughts if you're enjoying our 3 ABM
Bible Q&A then tell your friends each
Monday we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's holy word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand to have your questions
answered on a future program just email
them to us at bible QA 3abn.org
[Music]
5 that's
6182280065 is more than just about our
body God cares about us and it really is
involved with our relationship with him
and I want to end with 1 Thessalonians
523 and 24 that says now may the God of
Peace himself sanctify you completely
and may your whole Spirit soul and body
be preserved blameless at the coming of
our Lord Jesus Christ he cares about all
of us and the last part last part of the
verse is this he who calls you is
faithful who also will do it amen amen
amen
I just want to be poor in spirit I just
want for me to I want the Lord to just
fill me with his spirit because I know
my lack and I know that I can't do it
without him so I just I just want to be
this this study was really good for me
as well so I really want to be poor in
spirit amen
amen you contribute so much praise the
Lord amen shell my thought is to the
person who wrote in asking who is Jesus
you may want to watch 3ab and we have a
series called spotless the Everlasting
Covenant the companion book that God
gave me for that is called spotless
experiencing the Everlasting Covenant
through righteousness by faith it took
12 chapters go in from Genesis through
to identify all the Covenant language
which helps us identify who Jesus is so
you might want to watch the program
titled the big reveal amen thank you I
want to share Psalms
143:1 Lord hear our prayer give ear to
our please and in your faithfulness Lord
please answer me and in your
righteousness just want to thank you for
spending this uh last hour with us you
have many options in life but thank you
and uh just want to tell you how much I
appreciate each one of you and our
prayer for you is of course continue to
love Jesus he loves you
[Music]